when you look at the United States at
the moment and do you think about our
future one of the things that you might
ask is what are we good at you know we
used to be good at creating jobs but
we're not so good at creating jobs we
used to be good at building bridges or
highways or infrastructure we're clearly
not doing that we haven't done that for
50 years we used to lead the world in
innovation but the innovation is coming
from other places in the past ten years
what have we led the world in and the
one thing we've really led the world in
is creating inequality we have become
accidentally and unfortunately a world
leader in this and we were coming out of
a decade in which the results have been
kind of horrifying for the first time in
US history we've had a decade in which
we've had a net loss of jobs but we've
also seen social mobility decrease and
inequality continue to increase so much
so that last year which was a year of
recovery for the United States 93% of
the benefits of the recovery went to the
top one percent of the population and
there are 450 richest Americans have a
net worth equivalent to that 150 million
forest Americans that's not just an
interesting cocktail party statistic
that's a complete breakdown of our
society as it was envisioned as an
opportunity society technology
industrialism and capitalism have made
America richer on an average basis they
have made our GDP go up on an average
basis and for most of American history
when GDP goes up everybody benefits jobs
are created when productivity but goes
up everybody benefits money is passed on
down through the system but somehow over
the course of the past decade or two
what has happened is more and more of
the benefits from economic
have gone to fewer and fewer of the
people because executive compensation
has gotten to the point where CEOs
instead of making 50 or 60 times what an
employee made 30 years ago they may now
make 300 times or 400 times what an
employee made we are taxes for the
people at the very top are at the lowest
level they've ever been in American
history by a dramatic dramatic amount in
the middle of World War two the highest
tax rate for the richest Americans was
92 or 3% we're almost three times what
it is today
so that has had an effect and of course
if you're in a really privileged
position in a privileged industry and
the wall street or you're at the top of
a big company we have got the system set
up that you can influence political
outcomes you can influence who gets to
pick the regulator's you can influence
who gets to pick the judges in a way
that almost guarantees that as the rules
get written even if there's a little
regulatory squeeze or pinch here or
there
net-net you're gonna benefit and the
rest of society is gonna fall behind and
so we've essentially institutionalized
inequality and we've accelerated in so
doing this sort of descent into ever
more unequal society so through
democratic means we need to create
institutions that have the power to
counterbalance to rein in to regulate to
ensure that companies and the rich pay
their share and advance our interests as
a society as a whole that we get away
from the notion that the purpose of our
society is simply wealth creation simply
having the highest GDP you know you can
have a society with a very high GDP
that's all one company and most of the
people are living in poverty and that's
what we've seen in the past decade GDP
goes up but the life of the majority of
people goes down the problem gets worse
when you deal at a global level because
national power stops at borders but
global corporations are able to operate
out in a space where there is no
regulation at all whether that's in
global derivative
or it's in you know Internet commerce or
it's simply their ability to go from one
tax regime or one IP regime in one
country and go to another place that's
got a more relaxed regime it's sort of
venue shop around the world and so we
need those governance mechanisms on a
global stage as well as on a national
stage and that's challenge is even
greater because here an individual could
you know cast a vote file a referendum
run for office have an impact through
existing institutions we don't have the
institutions on the global level to
provide that counterbalance